[Music]
foreign welcome to the pretty intense
podcast if you would please do me a
favor and take a second and hit the
Subscribe button that means so much to
me and the whole team who put in a lot
of effort to make these shows to get
great guests and keep bringing the truth
to you so please hit subscribe Today's
Show is with Dr Gabrielle Lyon she is a
board-certified family medicine and
fellowship-trained physician in
nutritional science and geriatrics I've
been watching Gabrielle on YouTube for
years for at least two years maybe three
years she just brings so much knowledge
about this sort of protein conundrum I
went through my own phases of not
knowing do we really need protein how
much protein should we have what does it
do she explains just why it's so
important how to build it how to
maintain it it's just great information
that I think everyone needs to hear This
Is The Stuff of longevity this is how
you stay healthy for a long long time so
your function at 80 is still quality
Gabrielle has a book coming out in
October called Forever Strong she knows
so much about how to keep skeletal
muscle how to make it how to maintain it
and the benefits of it as well as the
fact that she is just a cool badass
woman I really think you're going to
enjoy this episode well I'm glad that
we're finally doing this gosh I know
I've been listening to your stuff for
years like I feel like I I looked back
because I want to see like what the
timeline was of I felt like you just
hadn't really popped yet like in a way
that you have in the last year or so I'd
say and and I look back I'm like yeah
man you were the YouTube videos with Don
were the ones that I watched I watched I
feel like it was over it was you and Don
most of the time and um you know it was
like three years ago basically I feel
like YouTube because I watch everything
on YouTube I'm a YouTube guru I love it
I love it I love it you say that you
know I've been really working hard to
try to get this message out there and
I'm just I've just been waiting for
people to catch up and just waiting you
know this is can have the potential to
shift the Paradigm just of how we do
things and you know Don is a world-class
expert and that's actually I dedicated
my book to him this is taking all the
research from bench to bedside and
this could change the trajectory of
people's lives
so I'm so glad that you watched his
videos and that you like and he's in his
mid 70s yeah yeah well you had to wait
for the vegan vegan flame to burn out a
little bit
um I'm sure it will Circle back the
truth it's like fashion I'm sure it will
Circle back you know I did this tedx
talk and for eight minutes it's an eight
minute talk so the tedx maybe it's 10
minutes I submitted 52 references for
eight minutes and they flagged it for
being outside of guidelines
whether they felt like it wasn't
scientifically sound or any of these
other things but was so interesting in
the same uh frame They are promoting a
CEO of a meatless company that wants to
replace meat with
um mushrooms and talking about the
impact of
cattle on the world or the impact of
cattle on our climate in the U.S and it
just it's not true I'm talking about
being strong and I'm talking about how
are we going to maintain the health of
our skeletal muscle how are we going to
be stronger better humans and how that
potentially could change the way people
experience aging and how I have my
moment with not eating animal meat I ate
fish I like went for I totally got
sucked in I watched what the health and
I was like oh it's rocking my
meat-eating world because I love meat I
mean short ribs steak chicken all of it
like you name it pork chops like and I
was like well I feel bad I guess I can't
I guess I should just not contribute to
the problem then like the masses are the
voice right so if I just stop buying it
they'll stop putting it on the shelf and
so I kind of went through this little
phase it was like 2017 end of 17 and
then that lasted for a couple years
where I like only really ate fish at
night rarely ate steak and really didn't
eat anything how did you feel terrible
terrible like I had way less energy
I mean on with a Cascade of problems to
come from that point on basically like I
lost my whole body and whole like
well-being for at about 2020 it was
finally time and like through stress and
it's never just one thing but like that
was one of them and um I think for sure
one definite effect is I had heavy metal
poisoning oh interesting so I mean like
I mean because then on top of eating all
the fish with the Mercury is that I now
is consuming plant protein for my like
additional protein because I was still
trying to eat protein but I would have
pea protein and they say that those
kinds of proteins are any kind of plant
basically absorbs the metals and so now
I have more metals from that too and you
know my Mercury level was so it's
supposed to be under five and it was
170. you know like I was I've actually
never seen anything that high and I I
take care of War Fighters so that is
exponentially High yeah so I mean I'm
I'm all behind you on this whole strong
meat lean muscle mass like all of it
because that was also I mean I gained
weight my body wasn't the same it just
but I always knew I felt so much better
on animal meat and I commend you for
being able to speak out on that because
in the narrative and in the environment
that we live in it's kind of like social
media has taken over and it's very
damaging to People's Health and Wellness
right so you have this experience where
you got on this kick and luckily you're
able to vocalize it and again I don't
think that we should only be eating meat
and I don't think that we should only be
eating plants but we can't dehumanize
something that helped develop our brains
that helped develop our bodies it just
it doesn't make sense in a way in which
they're painting animal products in
general
and it seems as if there's no advocacy
for it but it seems as if this constant
discussion about how we should go more
plant-based is really going to affect
women and children it's going to affect
our military and it's going to affect
our aging population
and that's a problem and I don't see who
it doesn't affect like you're just
you're naming thing I don't see who it
doesn't affect well when we have
conversations about meatless Monday and
when we have government
institutionalized decision making the
unintended consequences of that where
other people can make their own
decisions but for example if my child
goes to school and they tell her that
they're going to have meatless Monday
what kind of effect is that going to
have over the long term for her it's
it's not going to be great and it also
poisons her way of thinking about things
yeah yeah there's a whole lot of
institutional rules in the world that
are Highly Questionable these days
especially for children which I do want
to talk about kids at some a little bit
later on protein being that topic right
now
um what are you seeing are the main
reasons to consume protein and what are
what are the upsides downsides like
frame up your vegan for me at your meat
eater okay dietary protein is
unfortunately or I suppose fortunately
now the most controversial macronutrient
it's probably been that way but you know
I've been studying for this in for 20
years and it wasn't 10 years ago it
wasn't really controversial right so you
had these groups of
um vegan vegetarian and it was happening
but it's still a very small percentage
of the population two percent or less of
the population
but dietary protein as it relates now
has gotten much more controversial
likely because it has a face because it
relates to Animal Welfare it has a face
it just is very emotional for people and
one of the broad topics we'll just say
protein so there's plant protein there's
animal protein protein is made up of 20
different amino acids nine of which are
essential these amino acids all have
dual roles in the body it can't just be
collectively discussed as protein which
it is by the way but actually there's 20
different amino acids in various amounts
that make up one individual protein
Source that's really underappreciated
what we're going to see it's something
called the eaa9 is going to come out and
that is a way in which we think about
each one of those amino acids as
individual nutrients which is
fascinating we've never talked about it
before we have only looked at dietary
protein as it relates to this is plant
protein teen and this is animal protein
but the reality is is each of those
individual amino acids have its own need
and it's well they usually come in
clumps though right it's usually like
these ones come with this and these ones
come with that it's not like you pick
specifically big I better get an ounce
of fish should have salmon in an ounce
of bison and an ounce of you know it's
kind of like clumped into different
categories but you know but it's
obviously being analyzed on a on an
individual level now and I'm wondering
what the Cascade effect is of that is
with our supplementation I think that's
very a very intelligent point is that
why have we come to this place if
individuals were eating a combination
nutrition plan where they're eating both
animals and plants probably way less of
an issue but because of the influence of
this plant-based nutrition ideology we
are not meeting some of these individual
amino acids and while on the short term
is it an issue probably not but long
term we don't know the potential
Downstream effects not just talking
about muscle Health we're talking about
all these other things
cognitive hormone sleep exactly over
time certain amino acids help with gut
intestinal lining other amino acids how
my gut was a mess too just to make sure
we cover that base of course dysbiosis
leaky again but it was a wrap but also
you're a high level athlete and we do
see I take care of athletes in my own
personal practice and it's interesting
the the higher an individual goes in
their sport the it's not people think oh
these athletes and being at the top is
really healthy it doesn't totally go
like that because you do have to you're
laughing is you know it's true is there
there are certain things that there's a
give and take to be at the top of your
field is not necessarily in alignment
with health but hopefully there are
seasons to it right so there's the
repair and rebuild season there's the
push season and you take the off season
to recover so no
um but anyway these individual amino
acids
um when we think about what we need we
go through protein turnover your gut
your hair your skin your nails your
entire body system and I went to
too I mean look at you now oh my God my
hair was terrible just terrible and look
at you now total babe right completely
all together
um so dietary protein helps with protein
turnover protein turnover is happening
all the time as we age we have this
inability to keep up we've all seen this
with our parents perhaps their skeletal
muscle goes down and all kinds of low
levels of inflammation that ultimately
we see over time
um you know and then when we think about
why protein is important is it's
essential carbohydrates you can make the
need of essential fatty acids super
small but you cannot replace dietary
protein you have to eat it yeah yeah
okay or another you have to eat it the
make would be trying to do like a
impossible burger or whatever or
the make would be for a hundred grams of
protein you'll generate 60 grams of
glucose you don't have to eat
carbohydrates your body can make it yeah
yeah yeah if you eat lean enough meats
you will get like I mean I wore a CGM
and the only thing that doesn't spike
your blood sugar is fat so your body is
obviously converting some of the protein
protein does cause a phase two insulin
release there's the phase one from
carbohydrates which is pretty robust and
then there's the second phase of
pre-formed insulin and your body will
release insulin so absolutely but the
reality is is the amount of essential
fatty acids that you need it's not that
much but you do need dietary protein and
in fact the average protein intake for
an individual in the US for a woman in
the U.S is around between 60 and 70
grams a day I've been counting and I
know portions and macros like pretty
well how much protein are you eating uh
about 130 a day I weigh about 115 ish
and I weigh I mean I would eat more
protein I'd like to but I'm also trying
to get enough this is another topic is
complex carbohydrates and and
carbohydrates in general
I used to not eat them but I do think
that it had a bit of an issue with my
thyroid and my hormones but when I see
people eating and they'll they'll be
like oh I'm so full and I look and I'm
looking at what they just ate and I know
and I just know and I'm like you ate
lettuce and half of your chicken I know
you're not full you just ate about you
know 190 or 200 calories like I'm I'm
like I know you didn't you know I your
dressings on the side like I look at
this and but women I feel like they look
at meat and they just think if I eat it
I'm gonna just turn into like the Hulk
or something yeah these are it is very
common not in lifting weights between
that and lifting weights women for some
reason have just it's just a total
disservice it's very hard to put on
skeletal muscle and very hard I know I
know it's so hard I agree I know you're
super rip like I know you lift weights
like crazy I do and I'm also really tiny
I'm about 180 pounds by the way yeah and
you're five one so am I are you really
yeah
best friends yes yeah it's hilarious
um so yeah you have to train you have to
train and you have to eat and it's not
easy you have to create a stimulus so
that you can put on muscle and for women
oftentimes they think that salad and and
eating very light and doing why they're
going to be doing walking and and that's
great in yoga and pilates all of that is
great but I really think if we care
about long-term metabolic health
strength body composition then you do
have to lift because it does get easier
right so you want to protect what you
have while you have it it doesn't it
doesn't get easier so when you have more
skeletal muscle
um what are the biological benefits of
that like well you know the fizzy a lot
like you look at someone and you can
like literally see shape in them
beautiful but what are the biological
benefits when you have healthy skeletal
muscle there's healthy skeletal muscle
and there's unhealthy skeletal muscle
what yeah are you ready you can be
ripped and be unhealthy skeletal
probably not probably
but unhealthy skeletal muscle is when we
think about a marbled steak when we
think about obesity it's not just that
there's fat on the body but you know we
talk about visceral fat which is fat
over the organs there's also fat in and
around skeletal muscle that would be
considered unhealthy skeletal muscle
okay okay you also can have indications
of unhealthy skeletal muscle if you are
young lean and sedentary you don't have
to be overweight to have unhealthy
skeletal muscle you can simply be
sedentary some of the early works of
this came out of Yale uh I think it was
kit Peterson's lab where they showed 18
year old college students
young healthy not overweight lean but
showing signs of insulin resistance all
because skeletal muscle is unhealthy
being sedentary is what unhealthy is
what creates the the so it's saying that
you have muscle and fat then yes and
what happens is is when we think about
skeletal muscle it really is an organ
and it really is about Locomotion and
movement when it is
static think about a pool or a pond that
doesn't you don't drain the water and
you don't recycle the water it just gets
low levels of inflammation stagnation
all of the things I mean obviously a
pond doesn't get low levels of
inflammation but your body pain healthy
skeletal muscle you have to go through
flux you have to empty the proverbial
tank okay the glucose then exactly it's
like you've got to dump the glucose
triglycerides yes you have to utilize
you have to utilize these sources of
energy so you're saying that it truly is
like the marbled steak it's the marbled
steak so you're so there's too much heat
fat in the muscle it's the marbled steak
yes in and around skeletal muscle is not
good
healthy skeletal muscle number one
skeletal muscle is an organ system take
this right off the table it is not your
skin skin is not the largest organ
skeletal muscle 40 some percent
um Danica and I I don't know we're
probably 50 muscle
they're for everybody else who's 40.
we're like you know all five five foot
five we don't have a lot more space I
mean like come on
um so when you think about skeletal
muscle and how do you build and maintain
healthy skeletal muscle what does it do
number one metabolic currency which I've
talked a lot about which you know if
you've watched any of those lectures
with Don metabolic sync glycogen
disposal it's where you move right fatty
acid oxidation okay
um body armor we know if you fall if you
get cancer if there's some kind of
catabolic crises this is what you are
going to use to protect yourself going
through periods of starvation yes you'll
use adipose tissue yes you'll use
skeletal muscle
really important for mobility and
strength also important for
um the secretion of myokines
which is we've heard a lot more about in
the last few years which we have right
I've been talking about this forever but
it's interesting because it's not easy
nor is it routinely measured in clinical
practice I mean we tried we were looking
at interleukin-6 and it just it doesn't
it's very difficult to correlate some of
these things because it's so new
especially in the US they're doing a lot
in Copenhagen but in the U.S it's just
it takes a long time it takes about 17
years for the information in the
research to come into clinical practice
it just takes time
we gotta move okay
let's go let's go Italy unless I'm with
you I'm with you but it takes a lot of
time so also when you contract skeletal
muscle it does release myokines myokines
for example interleukin-6 is a big one
as it relates to balancing inflammation
lowering systemic inflammation helps
with nutrient partitioning meaning how
do we utilize fats and glucose it
stimulates bdnf in the brain for
neurogenesis memory cognition 300 plus
different myokines I think one of my
favorite effects of muscle is just being
able to eat more probably for me at this
age maybe when I'm 60 and then 80 I'll
be happy for other reasons but you know
the Metabolic Effect of muscle I think
is really important I think if most
women knew that the more muscle mass
that they could put on essentially if
healthy lean muscle mass then you know
they would be out of their 1200 calorie
prison and the more mitochondria you
generate yeah which is also super
important I mean I do things to
upregulate my mitochondria I take pills
for it I do red light that's right I'm
just curious what kind of pillar are you
taking for it
it's um have you ever heard of a guy
named Kashif Khan he has the DNA company
oh I do yeah yeah kasha's great I met
him a couple years ago and he was doing
genetic testing on women that were
getting explants on some common factors
with women that um that needed a
mountain that were sick from them so
that's how we started but it's one of
the one of his mitochondrial pills from
his I'd have to look and see what the
ingredients I'm very interested in I've
been using a lot of urolith and a I
don't know if you've heard of that no
yeah it's very fascinating it's just
it's so interesting the way that it
impacts mitophagy and mitochondrial
regulation if you can leverage it it
improves endurance and strength yeah
super cool sounds like a good one added
to the list I mean there was a point in
time I was probably eating 30 or 40
pills a day when I was deep in deep in
the gut rehab and the whole dysbiosis
and God I don't miss those days well
there are obviously so many great
features to protein to close the loop a
little bit on protein itself or I should
say animal protein is it possible for
someone to not eat animal protein and be
able to like really truly achieve the
highest level of Health that could be
achieved through animal protein is it
really possible I feel like everyone
wants to say it is but I don't know I'm
going to give you I'm going to give you
an evidence based answer I'm going to
tell you some of the flaws and the
difficulties with answering that
question the evidence would support if
you're young and training and you're
getting dietary protein whether it is
from plant or animal you could do either
or that's just for a muscle mass and
strength standpoint
there aren't long-term studies that are
controlled that we know of it just
doesn't exist
professionally I do not believe that
that is possible I think that we have to
really think about food as a food Matrix
I don't know you could supplement
creatine you could supplement taurine
but it's almost the same thing as saying
well I don't really need to eat fruits
and vegetables or phytonutrients as long
as I'm getting it in a pill I think it
would be impossible to do all of that
I also believe that animal-based
proteins are rich it's not even that I
believe they are highly bioavailable but
your original question is could we could
someone reach the optimal level of
Health without eating animal products I
think professionally
um I I'm not sure how someone would do
that right well you see patients I mean
anecdotally you can you can use your own
generated experience to say no this
didn't it didn't work it didn't work it
didn't work since 2006. I've been seeing
patients and I do not believe
I think on the surface we can maintain
skeletal muscle mass but long term you
know you got to think about iron
deficiencies people would have to take
iron pills probably would benefit from
taking creatine certain B vitamins it
would be a lot a heavy burden and even
then again the magic about food is
eating in it is eating the whole thing
we're not trying to eat a bunch of power
powders or make it so where you know
we're going to be like how the future is
is we're probably just going to be
eating a bunch of Elemental type
nutrition plans which is scary
what about you know there's been you
know in life you go through life and
people get sick and they get cancer or
whatever and
you know what have you seen in your
experience and from the literature about
diet diet wise what's the best for
people in those positions where they're
unwell whether it's cancer or some sort
of some sort of disease because I've
seen so much varying degrees of approach
to it you know you said the whole food
is important and there's been people I
know that have done juice and it's like
just you know I I I would I wonder for
myself if it happened to me what would I
do because like my my I think we relate
my like aggressive like blunt brain goes
you just eat meat that's it or
starve like you starve it out of you or
you just eat meat but that alkaline
environment isn't going to be available
anymore or I'm gonna make it alkaline so
but I think if I was in the position I'd
Wonder
um I think that there's a couple ways to
approach this number one is there
evidence that methionine restriction
which is one of the amino acids would
help with potentially chemotherapy so
methionine is deficient in like a vegan
diet would be a low methionine diet
so it's very low in Plants it's a
limiting amino acid it's high and
available in animal products I will say
that there is some evidence to suggest
that a if somebody has cancer a method
again it probably depends on the type of
cancer I was just reading yeah this is
General yeah I was looking at this
literature because I'm super fascinated
in the individual nutrients and so with
methionine restriction is there a
potential to improve chemotherapy
outcomes and to quote starve cancer
because they seem to feed off of
methionine again it depends on the
cancer I think that there is some
benefit
but then there are other cancers where
people talk about a ketogenic diet
ketogenic diet would be 70 plus percent
fat
would be different than potentially this
lower methionine diet
so I think that there's multiple ways in
which one would approach it I would also
say that on the flip side one of the
things that kills people with cancer is
cancer cachexia
and that's a highly metabolic process
that destroys skeletal muscle
so then the question becomes where are
you on survivability
cancer cachexia patients do better with
protein and exercise
again it is where are you these
progression are you at the point where
you're doing chemotherapy are you at the
point where you need to protect skeletal
muscle which everybody is and how do you
navigate those things
and I also think that protein does not
cause cancer yeah or do I think that red
meat causes cancer uh one of you know
you when you hear these things you have
to ask well what is the mechanism of
action
why would this conversation be that red
meat seems to be worse for you than
smoking think about it red meat in the
in mainstream media
red meat is killing the planet causing
cancer I don't know you name it probably
red meat is responsible for the next
five things smoking doesn't even do that
that's fascinating right right just lung
cancer right so your test yourself so
what is the mechanism of action and
people will say the mechanism of action
is this complex called mtor mechanistic
Target of rapamycin but that is not a
cancer initiated a cancer cancer
initiation Factor what it is is it's a
growth promoter it's a it's a protein
kinase and it's important it's in all
cells in the body and it's important for
growth it's muscle and liver and
pancreas and by the way when you push
mtor Pathways it's not just protein that
pushes it it's excess calories
carbohydrates is all these other things
like a building mechanism then it's a
it's a it's responsible for muscle
protein synthesis it is I think that's a
great way to think about it it is a yes
that's that is a good way to think about
it so that is the way that people will
talk about
um protein and cancer red meat
but it doesn't hold up because
it just doesn't hold up onto
carbohydrates because it's been one of
those things that you know I've looped
around about too of course I had my
moment with protein like maybe it's just
a myth that we need protein yeah don't
worry I really thought that for a second
because I was like maybe it's just
propaganda we you know the narrative is
getting each a protein so with
carbohydrates you know I didn't go
carbohydrate free but I was only
consuming them through
um you know squashes and I was paleo
paleo for seven plus years
um no grains no beans fruits squashes
some potatoes but very little complex
carbohydrate in the nature of rice and
oats and various different things like
that but at the beginning of the year I
started having it again and I lowered my
fat and increased my carbohydrate which
I get can be an energy exchange of like
this will give you more readily ready
energy throughout the day but I just
generally like my body responded and it
was a really positive thing and you know
I just wonder too how much damage I did
to my thyroid while I was in this
protein hole or I should say protein and
fat hole first of all you feel great and
you look great right so I would say you
probably didn't do damage and your diet
sounds just like my dog oh I did damage
normal my thyroid I don't even know if
the numbers are up I don't even know if
I should trust the numbers because they
have not come up in two years but also
we don't just treat off Labs if you are
feeling good I mean granted if your TSH
is super high then that's an issue but
you know depending on what your Baseline
is you have to really think about how
you feel and that's where our medicine
comes in
I think that the body I know that the
body is incredibly capable at healing
itself it wants to be in homeostasis it
wants to be better if you give it the
tools to be better it wants to be better
you know
um yeah so I don't believe that you did
any inherent damage truly I think that
we test more than we ever have many
women have low thyroid it's just for
whatever reason maybe it's an iodine
issue maybe it's that we're just testing
more who knows I had so many tests done
the last couple of years everything from
you know my blood work for leaky gut and
stool samples that's the most humbling
thing anyone's ever done I mean pooping
in oh my God scooping your own poop
I mean like the worst not gonna do the
test I sent you you sent me a test if
you tell me to do it I'll do it like I
am a good good patient blood test for
everything and um you know on another
note my mom my mom has gone through
various different sort of health issues
and the most recent one was her I think
it's called the ca125 which is a cancer
marker for ovarian and she uh it was
elevated it was like right on the cusp
and then it jumped and so she was very
scary well she went and she had surgery
had her ovaries removed and they did a
very they they tested while like like
first initially did sort of a wash I
guess and they take they take samples
and they test to see she had no cancer
and there was absolutely nothing no
issues whatsoever they cannot explain
the ca125 number but trust me like I'm
over in Europe praying in every single
church that I go into which is well
everywhere and I'm I'm I mean you know
unless it was the prayers that just
magically vanished made the uh made the
made what they saw vanish but they're
like they saw something they're like
there's nothing there it's we have no
idea we can't explain your numbers and
so my mom was curious too because I
always ask people I'm around like hey do
you have any questions and she's like
I'm curious what the legitimacy of
testing really is because whether it's
my thyroid never numbers never coming up
no matter how much T3 T4 supplemental
t33 through the day I take or my mom's
ca125 it's like maybe if you test it
everyone would have stuff wrong with
them I believe that that is a really
good point when it comes to cancer
there's two things that I typically
would recommend full body MRI and
something called The Gallery test or the
Grail test and it looks for uh multiple
different cancers that we don't have
ways to do early cancer detection and
then once you get those results you
compare it to the MRI and you have an
appropriate workup it's something that
we use for military operators again
something we use in the practice Hunter
seven I don't know if you've heard of
them but have been using it for our
soldiers so that there's early cancer
detection and and that's what I
typically recommend and then of course
keeping up to date on your colonoscopy
and your mammogram if you need it those
kinds of things yeah yeah beyond that so
would you take all testing with a grain
of salt then because
you know is there is it is it does it
feel completely conclusive like you know
to elaborate more on my own Labs I never
felt that bad like with my Mercury that
high as well as five other metals with
you know mold with low thyroid with
hormones in the tank my cortisol was
spiking in the middle of the night my
whole like hormonal profile was flipped
um I mean just low testosterone low
estrogen low progesterone I mean you
name it like
that's what all the testing showed and
do I feel remarkably different than then
no I felt fine then I feel fine now I
also want to point out something it's
interesting there are individuals that
have a threshold for capacity
that's exponentially higher and
we have to believe and know that you are
one of those individuals whether if I
were to replace how you felt then and
put your ring on someone else's body you
might have felt like a two out of ten
but again there is a capacity and a
certain kind of resilience that some
people have we see it with the SEAL
Teams we see it with individuals that
are uh going through buds or just
military operators there are certain
groups of people and certain individuals
that it doesn't matter how bad their
Labs look they don't acknowledge there's
kind of a disconnect between how they
feel and their ability to just perform
and execute and that's the truth mental
strength but also I think you're
probably also born like that you
probably would say okay if I'm tired or
I don't feel like it I'm I'm still gonna
like okay and actually now I'd say you
know the other day I came home I went my
friend and sister went up to the
CrossFit Games we got home I was like oh
I'm gonna go work out I gotta Lyft it's
a Monday we drove home Monday and Monday
Wednesday Friday let's go and I was
about ready to go and I was like Mom
I'm really tired I'm like I'm just not
gonna do I'll go tomorrow and I actually
listened to a small cue now if I get
like a small cue of like I'm tired or
I'm exhausted or I'm hungry like just I
just follow it and this is the
frustrating this is the this is the path
of Health that I I have come to realize
at least for myself is that and even
with talking with people is that I can
ask you what should I do and you're like
well
I need a lot more information and we
need to test it on you like everybody is
different there is definitely Baseline
information and generalities but when it
comes down to the micro differences
between people about what time of day to
eat how much what how much carbohydrates
like what kind of food it's like does it
agree with you or not I mean I didn't
eat eggs for like eight years because it
said it was super reactive and created
more leaky gut for me and I I it was the
saddest thing in the world because I
loved eggs but I started eating them at
the beginning of the year and I eat them
every day and I have no problem
and that's where you have to take you
have to understand certain tests are
validated and certain tests are not
validated food sensitivity tests are
typically non-validated tests they are
usually come up positive with things
that people have been eating if they
have impaired gut Integrity those kinds
of things just to really take things
with a grain of salt and look at the big
picture that being said there are some
core fundamental things that everyone
should do that would be when you think
about it circadian rhythm is really
important being consistent at the times
you eat the times you wake being outside
I do think that dietary protein is a
foundation for 95 of all people
because there's evidence to support that
as it relates to evidence to support
skeletal muscle these protein turnovers
all the other things that happen in the
body and also we know that certain
people can tolerate more carbohydrates
than others and really refining and
defining what that is the next layer to
that by the way Danica is
who is the person and what is the
archetype in front of you you will
always do better if I give you something
that is going to create a challenge for
you you are never going to be the kind
of patient that is going to be like I'm
so good I'm just gonna relax like I'm
just gonna Escape through that's never
going to go with you like you know me
because you know you that's true it's
true so that's never going to work for
you if I say all right Danica we've got
this nutrition plan the next thing that
we're adding in is we're going to be
doing cold plunge we're doing cold
plunge until you feel really
uncomfortable and then we're going to do
that that and that and then you'll start
to as we start to escalate the challenge
you will begin to do better
but you are never the type of person
that is going to be okay with okay you
know I'm good I'm just going to Coast at
this yeah yeah I think that that's a key
to understanding who is the person in
front of you and what is their their
archetype where do they function and
where is their domain of functioning a
lot of times when people work with a lot
of patients especially because patients
come with problems and even it could be
clients as far as like trying to achieve
something better you really are able to
psychology wise you can identify people
very quickly like that's probably pretty
easy for you within the first couple
minutes yeah because then you leverage
the person to get the best out of
themselves I tend to take care of hard
Chargers yeah I know exactly where their
weaknesses are I know exactly where
their strengths are and how we're going
to leverage them and I know when they're
going to get bored and when they're
going to fall off I mean it's so
predictable it's like so predictable
probably because we're a computer
simulation and we just follow like this
certain code we're a certain archetype
but either way it still works it works
and it's super predictable and I would
say if someone's listening to this and
they're like well what kind of archetype
am I I would say the first thing that
you need to do is figure out where your
weaknesses are we don't care what your
strengths are where where are the
weaknesses in which you are going to
fall off what are the actions you need
to do to become the person that you wish
to be and what is the health behavior
what are the health behaviors that need
to be imparted upon that individual yeah
yeah great advice so what do we do
um to build muscle we've talked about
consuming
um dietary protein what do we do to
actually build muscle and this is the
good news is not it's not rocket science
right it's how are you going to create
enough volume enough stimulus enough
Progressive overload to build healthy
skeletal muscle there's multiple ways to
do it but you are going to have some
kind of resistance and again it could be
body weight resistance up into a certain
point I personally think weights are an
easy way to go it could be
free weights it could be machines it
could be kettlebells you name it but
what you're really looking for is not a
modality you're looking for a stimulus
you would get 10 to 20 sets per muscle
group per week however you want to do it
but you do have to create enough volume
for a stimulus for the outcome of
skeletal muscle you do need
calories you need dietary protein and
you need stimulus and then of course
rust and Recovery what would you say to
for I mean I feel like guys do a much
better job of this they'll probably try
and always grab bigger weights than what
they really should probably have but
women tend to grab lighter weights than
what they really should have so what
would be your your verbal cues to help
direct them to the kind of weight that
they should be lifting this is
interesting because the evidence would
suggest that someone could do a lighter
weight and still get the stimulus
but I would say that really cheats you
mentally
how are you also going to build mental
resilience and build confidence
confidence is built in the arena doing
things that you haven't done before to
prove to yourself that you are capable
and that is why I typically suggest
women either get with a trainer there's
tons of online I have online workouts
right I put together this whole video
um a whole video series by the way which
took days to uh film for my book uh to
show you proper ways to lift proper
mechanics ways in which you can stress
the system to create an adaptation
while I can sit here and tell you you
can lift lighter weights to get a
stimulus yes you can I think the better
way to potentially do that is to tax the
system to live obviously with good form
heavier weights but if you're a light if
you're using a lightweight you can't
just keep using tens right because
that's not that's not creating a signal
to adapt it's just the same signal over
and over again so if you grab tens then
grab 12s and grab 15s like that would be
the point right you can't just keep
grabbing the light weight you would have
to continue to increase I mean you could
but you might be doing 100 reps got it
so yeah might be doing 120 reps but oh
after a period of time that's a lot of
time yep yep yep yep exactly maybe other
ways more efficient and effective ways
to leverage that okay and then with
protein timing is there if we can kind
of take it one level further is there
um certain protein timing that helps
with the building of muscle
no for the most part no really no
fantastic if yeah I mean get it in
within a 24 hour period I'll say when I
think about protein timing it not
necessarily about muscle but how do we
build a nutrition plan that will take us
forward to maintain optimal body
composition how do we build a plan that
allows us to lose body fat obviously you
care about calories but the way I would
design a plan is I would front load
dietary protein 40 to 50 grams the first
meal 40 to 50 grams at that last meal
and then for you you're at 130 grams of
protein that middle meal could be 30
grams of protein that's how I would
distribute your protein so that you
optimize again for muscle protein
synthesis you balance blood sugar
you are priming the tissue it's able to
sense all of the amino acids you're
overcoming any kind of nutrient sensing
resistance and then at the end of the
day
four hours from Bedtime right we're
keeping on some kind of circadian clock
you have your other 40 to 50 grams of
dietary Protein that's how I would
design it and wherever you work out in
that area in that time frame as long as
it's consistent I'm good with cool cool
but for your mom or your mom I would
have her consume protein after she
trains
she's a little bit older she's will say
that she's more mature if an individual
is a little bit older again
is does the 24 hour amount of protein
that full day of protein matter but when
you're a little bit older there may be
some benefit to optimizing dietary
protein after you train because there is
more blood flow the tissue is primed for
nutrients it could potentially be a good
strategy I heard Don say in something I
was listening to about you know as you
get older you don't need as many
calories and I'm really curious about
that because
you know my understanding is is that
muscle cost calories and so as you get
older you generally would be less less
movement probably a little bit more
sedentary and you probably have less
muscle mass so I would say that that's
that seems like the conclusion in my
understanding to caloric needs more than
just like age itself yes I would say age
in and of itself there's some evidence
to suggest that potentially we become
more insulin resistant
I would say if an individual is highly
Physically Active then it isn't ages
it doesn't really matter the age but we
don't have a lot of studies that support
very active individuals throughout their
life the majority of older individuals
are very sedentary yeah yeah exactly
that's what would explain it for me
which is incentive to stay active and
keep your skeletal muscle uh it's the
it's the tissue you could really do
something about and it will protect you
as you age and it's not as if the
calorie it's not as if age in and of
itself changes everything the activity
goes down put I mean potentially
appetite goes down but we don't know
what really active there's not a huge
data set a very
highly active individuals that we're
studying I want to answer this curiosity
about blood sugar and
things now that have been introduced
like ozympic to
increase insulin if we become more
insulin resistant these sort of things
help bring blood sugar down and make you
less hungry various different things but
um I mean I wore a CGM and my idea was
like oh I you know don't want to
increase my blood sugar ever right so I
do whatever it takes but then you know
other people I've spoken to they're like
no it's healthy to have if you eat and
blood sugar comes up comes down if it
doesn't come down that's a problem but
this is a normal physiology
physiological reaction to food so is
blood sugar going up obviously we don't
want 400 that's a problem but you know
spikes in blood sugar and coming down is
that a problem or does that actually
wear out the mechanism of insulin coming
in to bring it down and then kind of
speaking to this mozambic craze that
we're in and you know what uh what it
really is doing upsides the downsides
the variability in blood sugar is
there's some component to its normal
high levels of variability is is not
ideal I'm talking about high levels of
variability when blood sugar gets too
high that is the definition of diabetes
however
maintaining your blood sugar is supposed
to go up a little bit even if you eat
protein your blood will go up a little
bit the idea that I think a bigger issue
is when we utilize insulin which insulin
is a hormone produced from the pancreas
that moves glucose out of the
bloodstream into cells when we are
constantly using insulin as a Fail-Safe
mechanism to move blood glucose out I
don't think that's ideal
what and how would someone do that if
someone was having a very robust amount
of carbohydrates or glucose then you
subsequently will produce insulin or
release insulin and those kind of swings
because then after that potentially your
blood sugar can drop those kinds of
swings are not ideal because when blood
sugar goes too low then you have an
increase in catecholamines all kinds of
catecholamines and just other hormones
that
can disrupt this homeostasis over time
so that's that's one thought but yes
there is variability in blood sugar and
with that being said the blood sugar is
maintained it's tightly regulated it's
you're not getting major Ebbs and flows
it's pretty steady right uh your blood
maybe your blood sugar is 85 all day
long until you eat it goes up a little
bit comes back down and it maintains at
85 but it shouldn't go up to 300 and
then down to 60. large swings are not
ideal
the second component to that question
that you would ask me was ozempeg The
glp-1 Agonist or trisapatide which
Moderno is a glp Gia P1 agonists I have
never seen anything work better in my
entire medical career it is it
only that you are less hungry because
it's because if it was only about
discipline
I got that I fasted 24 36 18 for a whole
week forever like I didn't lose a single
pound like I I can do the and I dislike
being hungry in fasting it's not my
thing although I'm always willing to try
everything so what else is at play that
makes this work because
it's remarkable it does slow down
gastric emptying individual which is
what it's supposed to do I know there's
a lot of conversation about oh this is
creating gastroparesis and all of these
other things well it's kind of doing
what it's supposed to do I didn't see
that but okay again as a practicing
physician I've never seen anything work
better overall I think that we tolerate
a much higher body fat than we should I
think that this drug has exponential
benefits I have seen it work wonders for
individuals with binge eating disorder
or dysregulated eating patterns I I've
seen it really cut alcohol cravings
there's some mechanism I'll take it I'll
take it I'll take it no I'm just kidding
that was just for Europe where I drink
wine like every day oh man
but you're home now
um it can there's some evidence to
suggest that it Browns fat oh that's
good that's the uh function of cold
plunging turning white fat cells into
Brown fat cells which burn at a higher
metabolic rate so that would be a help
so there are different mechanisms and of
course it affects hunger improves
insulin sensitivity I do think that it
is a great benefit I think it's a great
benefit when used appropriately what is
like a minimum kind of run that you do
with it like would you say hey if would
you say three months and get off six
months and get off is this something
people can be on for years it is and it
really depends on the person I have many
patients that are taking it at a not
even a therapeutic dose very very low
dose I have had other patients that
don't lose weight until they get up to
therapeutic dose of say monjorno or
trisapatide some people lose the weights
come off of it and they don't actually
regain the weight there's a lot of
discussion saying that you have to be on
it forever I I haven't seen that in
clinical practice and they all also talk
about how you lose lean body mass if you
are eating dietary protein and your
resistance training in my clinical
agency that's why I'm sure that you
don't because I'm I know how important
protein dietary protein strength
training is so that's what I've heard is
that people you know you eat less but
then they have so few calories and
they're not making sure that they keep
their macros in check to maintain their
lean muscle mass and they do lose it
they the I saw something that was like
the half of the weight they lose is
muscle you don't want that and it's
preventable and it means that your dose
is probably too high and I've looked for
a mechanism of action to say what is
ozempic doing why how is it impacting
the pathways of skeletal muscle I
haven't seen that I haven't been able to
find again we have to think if something
is being repeated then what is the
mechanism of action as to why it is
happening and is it directly related to
the drug or is it directly related to
actions above and beyond the drug for
example
starving not eating and not training
I have not been even maybe
um by the time this episode comes out
there'll be some way in which there's
some mechanism of action but I haven't
seen it so it's good for longevity for
people and you know when people the
thing is too it's a Cascade effect once
the people lose weight and they start to
feel better then they go start to act
better too I I'd like to have a chat
about kids and like we've obviously
talked so much about dietary protein and
but like like how to take care of kids
you want to borrow mine do I want to
borrow your shirt you know look we I
swing them in circles we go ride
four-wheelers we we craft we make
bracelets and then I also tend to also
give some deep life lessons that I don't
know if they land but they're somewhere
deep in the subconscious there was one
little thing uh I'll tell this funny
story it was my sister's kids and riding
their bike and
um they're creative so they put rockets
on their bicycle and they take on and
she's able to take off the other
daughter got the bike and she wanted
rockets and I was like no I mean like I
don't have any Rockets left because I'm
like whether you think you can or you
think you can't you're right and I'm
like so all you have to do is believe
that I put a rocket on and so one time I
faked I did it but I didn't do it and I
faked it I was like all right there you
go your rockets on she took off and I
was like Jordan I gotta tell you
something I didn't put a rocket on
and she's like what I'm like I told you
if all you had to do is believe there
was a rocket on and then you go fast
these are the games I play mine are on
their way to your house now
that's awesome that's great my sister
has four kids so they'll be highly
entertained with me and all them do you
think that there is influence on
biological hormones I do there are a lot
of things within the environment that
potentially can disrupt the endocrine
system for sure what do we do about that
I'm not sure I mean the best thing that
people can do is
you know eat try to eat Whole Foods do
the best that individuals can try to
limit exposures to Plastics and
endocrine disruptors yeah that is the
best and only thing that I I think that
individuals can do but it's challenging
yeah you know it is definitely
challenging interesting it seems
confusing it seems surprising and just
can help but think of that there are so
many things in the world that are
poisoning us and especially in the
nature of food them trying to bile like
genetically engineer food and I I think
that it's it's very challenging and I
think
um
it's very hard on kids it's very hard on
parents I think that there's a lot of of
certain endocrine disruptors in the
environment that we're in well thank you
very much that's such great advice gosh
if you if you're not ready to eat
dietary protein now I'm not sure what
you need but
they have to I strongly suggest people
uh read my book Forever Strong took two
years to write and it's very
evidence-based and it talks a lot about
the influence of food so it'll tell
people exactly what they need to know to
how to live in the best version of their
body but what it also does is there's
also information about the history of
how we hear about food and that's very
fascinating about the budgets of these
you know you're talking about Monsanto
and some of these companies it talks
about the history of some of these
things well how's the food pyramid
developed how does that how who decides
on the food permit a social experiment
that went wrong that was a complete
disaster it's a social experiment well I
mean not totally but I guess everything
is kind of yeah
so they're that was a failure
but anyway the book talks about some of
the history of some of these things got
it what would your food pyramid be then
I mix I'm a dietary protein and fruits
and vegetables kind of girl
and I'll throw in some complex carbs
um pretty I would say I'm very balanced
high quality protein and fruits and
vegetables
what's an example of your breakfast
lunch and dinner I don't even know if
you eat three times one time five times
three times those this morning the kids
we all had Greek
um Burgers right burgers with burgers
and raspberries for breakfast
and I put some yellow potatoes on there
which they're now smashed into the
upstairs
and then they had to keep sending your
kids my way that's why
go to Auntie's house get out of here ATD
get out of here yeah so that's what they
had
lunch
packed them some salmon some cucumbers
some avocado
I mean so they eat healthy Whole Foods
and then on the way out of school
they're going to grab a bag of Cheez-Its
that it's going to be sitting here at
the counter no matter how many times I
tell them not to grab this at their
school they have this big I mean so
that's what's going to happen if you
control 90 of what goes into their mouth
they're far better off I mean I grew up
you know before we had a lot of
knowledge right it's like you know
um beef stroganoff and you know instant
potatoes sometimes and yeah you know
we know better now well thank you very
much congrats on your book
um I want to check that out I love
learning about the history of that stuff
yeah I'm gonna send you a copy people
can go to my website Dr
gabriellelion.com I have a ton of free
stuff that we're giving away with a
pre-order for the book workout videos
all kinds of things we're actually going
to have an in-person event in January
which I'd love to have you at if you
would like to comment often be so fun
and I could put you on the podcast at
the time at the same time I need to go
do an Austin Loop there's so many people
that live in Austin I'm a rock and roll
girlfriend January January well I'll
actually be there in um late or in
October late October for uh the F1 race
okay you tell me I'll be there all right
I'll bring my kids
um yeah so they can find it there and on
my podcast I have a podcast which you
are going to have to be on the Dr
Gabrielle line show
find me on Instagram Twitter newsletter
recipe books all my website awesome
when's the book come out October 17th
October 17th awesome
congratulations thank you go get the
book
all right my friend thanks for having me
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button